la reprise est fragile l'inquiétude
toujours palpable et le débat de jeudi
n'a rien fait pour rassurer l'industrie
de l'automobile
on sait que les fabricants sont inquiets
dit stephen harper avant de concéder
qu'il n'aimerait pas tout ce qu'il ya
dans l'accord le commentaire a surpris
le syndicat des travailleurs canadiens
de l'auto que l'on crée c'est une
réduction des exigences en matière de
pièces et de fabrication nord américaine
ce qui facilitera à l'importation de
voitures japonaises et mettrait en péril
selon l'économiste du syndicat 25000
emplois ici aujourd'hui stephen harper
tente de rassurer
évidemment il y aura des camps 1er mai
le gouvernement va assurer la protection
de nos secteurs et assurer que nous
avons sans nos intérêts dans l'économie
commerciale de l'avenir mais pour le
chef du npd ce n'est qu'un autre exemple
de bons emplois dans le secteur
manufacturier
sacrifié par les conservateurs il refuse
de le dire donc il ya lieu d'être
inquiet et pour les pièces automobiles
il est prêt encore une fois à vendre nos
emplois arabes'' c'est vraiment
déroutant
surtout en pleine campagne électorale
parce que même en pleine campagne
électorale le gouvernement poursuit les
négociations poussées par les états unis
et le japon
mais dans l'espoir aussi de pouvoir
brandir l'entente devant les canadiens
juste avant le jour du vote
la réalité c'est qu'on ne sait pas ce
que ce gouvernement est en train de
faire parce que encore une fois il
préfère tout faire dans le secret la
capacité et c'est pas ce que nous
attendons d'un gouvernement au 21ème
siècle qui se doit d'être ouvert et
transparent
les conservateurs auraient souhaité
régler l'accord avant la campagne
les négociateurs des pays membres
doivent se rencontrer le 26 octobre pour
tenter d'aplanir les derniers différends
et paver la voie à une rencontre des
ministres responsables au début du mois
d'octobre
si daniel thibault radio canada à ottawa